good morning Hank it's Tuesday so until
a few days ago the Malheur National
Wildlife Refuge in southwestern Oregon
was mostly known for its high-quality
springtime bird-watching
but then some people with guns decided
to take over the refuges headquarters
which is both a big deal like armed
civilians are in control of a federal
building and not that big of a deal like
it's not like the building in question
is the US Capitol regardless it gives us
occasion to consider some complicated
history and how ideas about public and
private property have shaped the United
States so these days Oregon is often
seen as one of the most progressive
states in the u.s. I mean I judge a city
primarily by the quality of its soccer
support and its public transportation by
which measures Portland Oregon's capital
might be America's greatest city but as
is often true with American history the
deeper you dig the more troubling it
gets
okay so around a thousand years ago the
northern Paiute tribe's wat Atika ban
moved into what is now the Malheur
National Wildlife Refuge
the first Europeans didn't show up until
the 1820s and their arrival of course
was catastrophic like most American
Indian groups the Wada teeka were
devastated by smallpox and other
european diseases as many as 90% of them
died from disease within 30 years of the
first European contact so by the 1840s
thousands of white settlers had made
their way west to Oregon via the Oregon
Trail this 2200 mile long wagon route
that today is primarily famous as a
video game in which you almost always
die of dysentery these settlers
encroached on northern Paiute land and
there were some conflicts but things
didn't really pick up until 1850 when
the u.s. passed the donation land claim
act that wall granted 320 acres of land
to any white man who settled and
cultivated the land for at least four
years and married couples could get 640
acres of land there were a bunch of laws
like this white settlement in Oregon
increased dramatically and by 1859 it
became a state quick sidenote
Oregon's first state constitution
contains some of the most shameful
language in American history for example
it outlawed black Americans even
visiting Oregon it was technically
illegal for African Americans to move to
Oregon until 1926 but right so by 1859
there were all these new white settlers
and Oregon thanks to the federal
government's land grants and not to
state the obvious or anything but
inherent to the idea that the u.s.
federal government could give land to
these white settlers was the idea
that the land in question was the US
government's to give the idea of
federally owned territory is established
in the Constitution and even today a lot
of the United States is owned by the
federal government speaking of which in
1872 the northern Paiute Tribe signed a
treaty with the United States government
establishing a 1.8 million acre
reservation called get this the Malheur
reservation the US government abided by
this treaty for all of 0 minutes with
settlers immediately encroaching upon
the reservation and then after in 1878
war won by the US Army the remaining
northern paiute s-- were taken off their
land and forcibly moved to washington
state
about a hundred northern Paiute families
were allowed to return to southwestern
Oregon at the end of the 19th century
but today their reservation is less than
1% of its original size and their tribe
has just 349 living members so in
summary for 800 ish years what is now
the Malheur National Wildlife Refuge was
northern Paiute land first because they
were the only people living there and
then because they negotiated control
over the land in a treaty with the US
government the US government then won
award deported the remaining Native
Americans and took control of the land
which it held until 1908 when President
Teddy Roosevelt declared it to be a
refuge for birds that Teddy Roosevelt he
loved birds especially hunting them so
that was the history of the Malheur
National Wildlife Refuge until a few
days ago when it became the de facto
headquarters of a militia claiming that
the u.s. government has no right to own
federal land Hank there are many
compelling arguments to be had about
government infringing upon the rights of
citizens but this is not one of them so
this militia argues that there's
something tyrannical about a
representative government telling the
people it supposedly represents to do or
not do things on certain land like if
the government is of the people and by
the people then how can the government
prevent me a person from doing whatever
I want on federal land the answer of
course is that the land doesn't just
belong to you it belongs to all of us
and collectively we've decided what to
do with it this is in accordance with
the US Constitution which states pretty
explicitly that the US Congress shall
have the power to and I quote dispose
and make all needful rules and
regulations respecting the territory or
other property belonging to the United
States and throughout US history the
Supreme Court has consistently upheld
the idea
federally owned and managed land the
counter-argument I've seen most often is
that land should belong to the people
who use it not to the government which
isn't so different from the way the
northern paiute treated land for most of
Oregon's human history however the
people using the land in question would
still be the northern paiute if the US
Army hadn't intervened on behalf of
white settlers in the 19th century in
American history there is no escaping
that fundamental fact our government
took this land from sea to shining sea
whether through purchase or war or
forced deportations or dishonest
treaties and then it apportioned some of
that land up as private property the
federal government has no rights to
federal land and never did then they
never had the right to give away
millions of acres to white settlers in
the 19th century this would render much
of American private property
illegitimate including by the way
probably my house Hank it seems to me
that if the Malheur national wildlife
refuges headquarters building doesn't
belong to the federal government that
built and paid for it than that building
and the Malheur National Wildlife Refuge
and in fact much of southwestern Oregon
belongs not to a militia but to the 349
surviving members of the tribe that has
lived on that land for most of its
history Hank I'll see you on Friday